leaders around the world are defending
the Paris climate Accord that President
Trump is abandoning the president
withdrew from the agreement where nearly
200 countries promised action to reduce
emissions blame for global warming the
president said the deal punishes
American workers and taxpayers in
response landmark buildings around the
world including New York's Empire State
Building were lit up in green over night
business leaders and other government
officials are blasting the president
major Garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning the
president's decision is a clear victory
for economic nationalists in this White
House led by chief strategist Steve
Benin who showed up early at the Rose
Garden just to soak up the moment it is
a defeat for Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson top economic adviser Gary Cohn
and Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner
interestingly Jared and Ivanka skipped
the rose garden ceremony so we're
getting out president Trump portrayed
his decision to abandon the Paris
climate agreement as a rescue mission
for the American worker not an
abdication of US leadership on green
technology or efforts to slow global
warming the Paris climate Accord is
simply the latest example of Washington
entering into an agreement that
disadvantages the United States the
president said the voluntary pact placed
too many restrictions on greenhouse gas
emissions and committed US tax dollars
to help less developed nations reduce
pollution I was elected to represent the
citizens of Pittsburgh not Paris mr.
Trump has called global warming a hoax a
lot of it's a hoax it's a hoax though he
said nothing about the science of
climate change in the Rose Garden Robert
Iger chairman of Disney and Elon Musk
CEO of Tesla announced their
resignations from the president's
business advisory council to protest the
Paris withdrawal said musk on Twitter
climate change is real leaving Paris is
not good for America or the world former
President Obama who helped seal the
climate deal in Paris two years ago did
not explicitly name mr. Trump but in a
statement sent during mr. Trump's
announcement said even in the absence of
American leadership even as this
administration joins us
handful of Nations that reject the
future I'm confident that our states
cities and businesses will step up we
don't want other leaders and other
countries laughing at us anymore
the president said under the agreement
China and India would continue to
pollute by using coal while the US would
be forced to limit coal-fired plants and
other fossil fuel use all he said to
curry favor with environmental elites it
is time to make America great again
thank you despite the president's claims
environmental protection groups say
India and China have both moved away
from coal and embraced renewable energy
sources according to statistics China's
coal use peaked in 2013 in Gale last
year China canceled more than 100 coal
power projects right thank you very much
major